non elle lui a dit non à trois reprises
mais il insiste la chanson de 1944 baby
it's cold outside mettait l'enceinte du
harcèlement sexuel
c'est un conte et au jeu répond envie de
la faire maintenant parce que je
voudrais pas blesser des gens souvent
interprété en duo et avec des rôles
inversés baby et squatte side est devenu
un classique du temps des fêtes chanté
entre autres par lady gaga l'arrêt
kutahya je veux c'est quand même assez
intense par contre je dois dire que la
façon de la chanson est fatigué à chaque
fin de partie deux couplets les deux
finissent en chantant il fait vraiment
froid dorothée donc je pensais comme
constante
le texte fait l'objet de plusieurs
interprétations
dans un passage la femme dit tu es très
insistants tu sais l'homme répond je le
vois plutôt comme une opportunité
c'est clairement une illustration
l'incarnation d'accueil sont violent
qu'on trouve dans cette chanson là je
pense que c'est clairement du
harcèlement sexuel qui est dépeint dans
la chanson parce que la fille dans les
paroles dit qu'elle veut s'en aller elle
l'aimé un malaise
[Musique]
dans la foulée du mouvement moi aussi la
chanson choque certains auditeurs et
face à la controverse lancée par une
radio de cleveland
les géants bell et rogers ne diffuse
plus la chanson si bbc a fait de même
sur deux sites de musique en continu
rien de tel du côté de radio canada
montré leur ai dit un peu de racisme si
beaucoup de racisme alors un brin qui
bouleverse la cense mythe a proposé
qu'une source du vieux c'est un brin de
tron qu'on cherche des bêtes noires va
mal partout et pourtant je suis
solidaire avec avec vraiment ne pas
forcer personne avec aucun prétexte pour
pas faire une grande grosse histoire
d'une chanson qui a été composé assez
naïvement je croirais et joliment
[Musique]
achat
une question demeure après baby inside
est ce que d'autres chansons subiront le
même sort ici louis fait le prix mais
radio-canada mauricie major
[Musique]
ce pas